PlayStation 5's latest 7.0 update brings
some long-awaited features and quality
of life improvements here's everything
you need to know the headline feature of
the update is Discord support originally
tested in beta discord's integration
into PS5 consoles will allow for vocal
chats across Hardware platforms and
share screen functionality one of the
other new features in the update is
variable refresh rate support at 1440p
resolution variable refresh rate or vrr
is where a screen can actually change
how often it is refreshing an image
ideally syncing with how many frames are
being generated a second by a game
without it for example you may have a
game that is generating frames between
30 and 60 per second depending on what's
happening in the game but a screen would
be locked to 60 hertz meaning that no
matter what the screen is refreshing the
image 60 times a second vrr in syncing
the screen's Reef refresh rate with the
frames per second output of the game on
display allows for smoother visual
performance just keep in mind that not
only do you need a display that supports
vrr you need to be using an HDMI 2.1
cable which if you're using the one that
came with your PS5 you are a join game
Icon in party chats a friend's play tile
so you can see which games are active in
your Social Circle and the option to
manually upload game captures to the
PlayStation app also included in the
update there are a couple of other
interesting features as well so make
sure to head to gamespot.com for the
full list if you have an Xbox series X
or S rather than the PS5 you've probably
been waiting on when to expect the
updated release date for bethesda's Star
field well surprise surprise it's not
happening in the first half of the year
like it said it would when the delay
from November 22nd last year was
announced Xbox and Bethesda have a
officially announced that Starfield were
released on September 6 2023 for PC and
Xbox series X and S more information
about the game will be a part of a star
Fields direct which was previously made
mention of by the companies around
Xbox's developer Direct in January we
now also know this star field
presentation will be happening on June
11th if you are plugged into the
industry and keep up with all its events
and showcases you might be thinking the
June 11th is awfully close to when Xbox
usually holds its annual major
presentation is the starfield's direct
to all we're getting it's not as it
turns out immediately preceding that
presentation Xbox will be having its
showcase and will theoretically be
showing off a ton of games that aren't
Starfield what those games are is
anybody's guess as by then most of the
Brand's big titles that have release
dates will have already launched save
for Starfield and Forza Motorsport it's
about time however we learned just what
the hell is going on with hellblade 2
senuous saga which was shown off with
the announcement of the Xbox series X
and the 2019 game awards over three
years ago rumors have also been
circulating recently that obsidians are
vowed as one of the games up next on the
Slate for the console while playground's
Fable reboot is still a long way out so
I'd say we'll likely hear more about the
former than the latter and maybe machine
games Indiana Jones one can only hope
what do you hope to see at the Xbox
games showcase let us know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
foreign